i can say i gave it everything i had i
mean every week you know so
you know and maybe it means an
interception on fourth and eighteen when
you're down ten because i don't care
uh
that it's gonna say two interceptions
you know i really don't it's just like i
ain't quitting
so i think that i think i think that
that um
doing it with so many guys over you know
14 years
and and going to the locker room win or
lose and i can say that gummy we're sure
we felt we fell short
but or we won you know uh but shoot i
couldn't try it any harder
so i think
two different kind of elements there but
uh i think that's the two things that
come to my mind
brow
fan all right thank you all right guys
philip rivers with his final post-game
press conference that was strong charges
likely will be his final post-game press
conference with the chargers jay glazer
was on call and coward chair yesterday
and glazer texted me last night because
it took on a life of its own glazer said
that the charges have moved on from
philip rivers so that became glazer's
reporting the charges have moved on from
philip rivers and glazer says i never
reported that but they've moved on from
from philip rivers i mean the bottom
line is he's moved out moved to
california i mean right they're not
bringing the guy back they're not his
cap number would be over 27 million if
they franchise tag him he was not very
good last year had 23 turnovers against
23 touchdowns he's not the guy that he
was it's time for the chargers to move
on for a variety of reasons peter
football and business reasons they need
somebody that's going to sell tickets
and psls and and help the chargers
become a team that la gives a crap about
so i think it's a mutual it's a true
mutual party we're here all the time
there's a mutual party this is a true
mutual parting he doesn't want to stay
and they don't want him to stay and now
he moves forward to wherever he ends up
somebody in the la market said to me
when i said hey look it'd be great if
the chargers could have tom brady on a
billboard
uh on the 405 you know you know in
orange county you know hey buy your
tickets 1 800 chargers and have a
picture of tom brady that'd be great
right and this person said well my point
is
i think if they had a billboard of teddy
bridgewater right now that would sell
more tickets than if they had a
billboard of philip rivers nothing
against rivers
but it's only that they want something
new yeah we've seen phillip rivers yeah
you know we saw what happened last year
and he's an older quarterback so it's
time to go it's time to move on and so
that's really where i think the chargers
would have to be mike here's the two
interesting points
about the next quarterback
of this team number one
if it is tom brady you know they've got
a lot of free agents who they have to be
worried about so who are they going to
spend their money on first of all and
second of all if they're not selling a
lot of tickets at this stadium and they
have the franchise relocation they have
all this other stuff to worry about you
tell me i mean
where's all this money going to come
from
if they're not selling a lot of luxury
seating in this new stadium
yeah i i mean
i i mean the chargers we we talked about
this a lot the chargers they need some
sort of fresh look you know star power
whatever it may be cam newton
yeah that makes a lot of sense it's a
great candidate for that that makes a
lot of sense you know with philip rivers
hey yeah it's over with the chargers
it's okay it was a great run it's
phenomenal you know it really is i got
so much respect for him i mean peter and
i were sitting here talking as we were
just watching the clip going man i
really like that guy and you talk about
the consecutive star streets i mean
streak it's it's that's an impressive
accomplishment to me it's way more
impressive than what eli manning's was
because philip like really hung in the
pocket all day long and would get
lambasted and then still would just get
up the big thing is is like what is the
next move guys where where what are the
teams i mean okay i mean jacksonville
bucks
miami i'm just throwing teams out there
you know i think he's in the same spot
eli manning was in and eli manning was
sufficiently self-aware to realize no
one's going to offer me 25 million a
year no one's going to say you're the
guy
no matter what and we're not going to
draft somebody in round one i think
that's what you run the risk of doing it
phillip rivers and you do it 20 minutes
i don't think he cares though almost i
of jameis winston and just go you know
what he's gonna screw it up and i'm
gonna take over at one point uh or maybe
bruce arians is gonna call him and say
let's just i'll let you duel it out with
jameis in training camp and the best man
wins i don't think you can pay both guys
i don't think you i don't think you're
going to keep winston if you're bringing
in philip
that's way too much money that's 55
million bucks on the cap for for
quarterbacks but i i would make this one
point somebody said to me this weekend
after the performance of justin herbert
at the senior bowl you know for those
who don't know justin herbert the
quarterback from oregon had a great
senior bowl week he was voted the best
player clearly and all that incredible
yeah and most people were thinking okay
two quarterbacks in the top five okay
but now what happens
if washington instead of automatically
taking chase young
what happens if washington says
we'll take three ones for this pick or
or three ones in something somebody
moves up maybe to number two to get
either tua or herbert and then somebody
moves up to get the other guy all of a
sudden everybody who becomes a
quarterback candidate let's say the
carolina panthers let go of of cam
newton and then they're in the
quarterback market they got to move up
for one of these guys and so everything
we're saying about philip rivers yes i
get it i understand but let's say you
take justin herbert and you say hey
listen we'll go get a josh mccown for
one year to sort of help him get ready
and josh mccown maybe can play for a
while but all i'm saying is i think
everything in the quarterback market is
bizarre
unanswered and unanswerable yeah until
we find out what happens early in free
agency and that's why the brady story
in new england is going to be a wrench
in the works to this it's the first
domino it's the first domino we have to
know if tom brady's staying because if
he's not that is a huge domino philip
rivers is out there and peter you know
something occurred to me as you're
explaining that there's an opportunity
for a phillip rivers post draft he can
just sit back and yeah see yeah there's
gonna be somebody somebody's there's
gonna be one musical
yeah and maybe it's bill belichick and
the new england patriots i could see him
saying i'll take rivers for a year and
then let's draft somebody and we'll see
what happens we'll take jordan love you
know in the second round he wasn't as
good at that and who i have no idea
where any of these guys are going right
but all i'm saying is that right now
this is the most unsettled quarterback
market and situation i can remember
around the nfl that i ever remember yeah
i'm with you i mean we have you're right
i mean you get and then you gotta take
into a fact like there's the teddy
bridgewaters and the andy daltons that
are going and what happens what happens
right as someone said to me with a with
a prominent quarterback
a general manager said to me what would
you think if we made an offer for taysom
hill
right no what would you think it how
much of an offer
what's too rich for the saints blood to
match right i said i don't know i said i
don't have any idea what the saints
really think of them but i do think i
honestly think that sean payton has it
in his mind
i'm really going to give this guy a shot
yeah oh he does
succeed about that
definitely reported yesterday they
envisioned him to be a franchise
quarterback he's already compared him to
steve young and this is part of the
delicate dance that they're doing with
the saints they'd like to keep drew
brees around but i think they're going
to make drew brees an offer that he may
not want to accept right
from a role standpoint and what happens
if drew brees as has been widely rumored
has a great television offer
not for nearly the money but he says you
know i've kind of accomplished what i
can accomplish here i'm going to go do x
on tv the fact that he's thinking about
it yeah to me is a little bit of very
large i mean you don't hear tom brady
going i'm thinking about retirement
right i'm playing he made the comment so
i think that is very odd that that
conversation is going in breeze that
tells me there's a little crack in the
armor a little bit to go okay all right
not sure if i really can do this or can
do it to the level i want to anymore all
right so we got to talk about brady for
a second because in my opinion what adam
schefter reported the patriots want to
know before free agency they want tom
brady's decision
tom brady for 20 years
has never had the ability to be free
and to go out and say hey let's see
what's out on the market out there and
now the patriots are saying okay we're
going to give you your freedom and by
the way if you don't decide by the first
day of free agency see you later we're
going on to somebody else but won't he
no but he'll know by then they're going
to know they're going to know the
scouting combine who wants him and who
doesn't right yeah but but does that
mean you just don't like them drawing
the hard line to a guy like tom brady i
don't understand why if you gave him the
ability to be a free agent if you said
you can be a free agent oh by the way
you can be a free agent but if you don't
decide by the first day of free agency
see you later here's the problem here's
a problem
they're going to be
stuck without a quarterback if they wait
around for tom brady to make up his mind
because then what if you say this
water's gone all you have to say to
teddy bridgewater is that who i'm sure
would love to play for belichick love to
play with josh mcdaniels all you have to
do is say to bridgewater give us still a
third day of free agency why does teddy
bridgewater have to decide because
because there may be another team that
says we want you right now this happens
all the time when they get into that 48
hour window where you're allowed to
negotiate with guys i'm telling you
teams call agents and they say here's
the offer we need to know right now and
if you don't tell me right now we're
moving on to the next guy
then i'd call their bluff and then you
may then you may not backing up jameis
winston in tampa that's the problem well
i mean i mean one um you know how new
england works this is the way they work
they don't care if it's brady or
whatever well that's not how robert
craft works well i guess bill billy
you're right it's the way bill belichick
works you're right and i think that
we'll know tom brady will know before
that deadline i would think they'll know
probably what they're going to do he'll
know what he's going to do but that's
the first domino quarterback situation
this is a crazy off-season and people
haven't gotten their arms around the
idea that tom brady may indeed leave the
patriots i think once people understand
that the entire wildlife will not people
realize that that might happen
nobody can picture it
new england they go together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports